something is happening with this new
ability people are taking this new
ability to measure everything as Rick
was saying not just us but all these
devices all this stuff we can do
something with this what are some things
we can do with it and one of the things
we're going to do with it is we're going
to measure ourselves and so then that's
what the meetings have been about who's
measuring themselves and it turns out
that anything that you can possibly
think of measuring somebody in the world
is tracking it right now and that we had
that Q asst international conference
just about two months ago and i said to
gary is there anything in the world that
you don't think someone's tracking right
now I had to really think you really
think I said I don't know anybody I've
never heard of anybody tracking how long
their toe nails are growing growing
right so that was the only thing I could
come up with earwax goodness County here
now we've doubled so I at the US
Conference I said there's nobody in the
world tracking their toe nail growth and
in this guy oh yeah so so so the idea is
is really doing that what we didn't get
to a member like you see we could get
him to give a talk we would find out how
you doing it what are you doing what are
you learning